today on our show all lady wonder women
screening hacks and all the trolls are
very upset about it that is so much more
right here today on fat man on Batman
[Music]
committing to Batman Batman I'm Kevin
Smith I am mark Barnard we got a bunch
of news in our fists that we're gonna
throw at you like luck be a lady tonight
hey guys I'm Nathan and he's sky and
we're doing a two-man version of Guys
and Dolls with no dog guys and Alvin our
dolls are action figures Wow thank you
my dad was always like that's a doll I'm
like it's an action figure he's like
it's a doll it's got a cone foregrip dad
now it also got a couple UJ kids pants
off and there's no dick it's a doll to
my wife that's my nickname chose me doll
oh I don't know why that's a sweet
enough for the [ __ ] jokes we're here
for the news hit him with the news in
them with the news we got the news news
hit him with the news what what
Universal you know Universal has
monsters
that's all univer Universal is so much
but they're trying to launch or Avengers
eyes they're Universal Monsters
characters AKA i was going to say akka
the new mummy movie that they're opening
right now Tom Cruise is their second
attempt to launch their universe the
first one was Dracula untold yeah and
they're like oh the dogs are excited
about that book [ __ ] you Dracula's old
rock chooses overnight only thing better
is just a dozen they did they got
Russell Crowe playing dr. Jekyll's mr.
Hyde so they eventually do that movie
they got Wolfman movie they could do
they got creature movie they could do
but they're gonna do all these Universal
monster movies and then bring them
together in one bash they're calling it
the dark universe which is such a why
not just the universal monster whoever's
come on like dark FL universe we don't
want to use the term monsters universe
it's called that yeah just look again
monster Palooza is that I mean do you
think they're like no nobody but we
can't sell monsters nobody wants a bio
monster it's like well then why you
making these [ __ ] yeah seriously also
Godzilla just made like a billion
dollars but people are okay with monster
use the word
monster don't be a monster cyst dark
embrace the monster dark universe is a
bunch of different things you only know
what it could be man no [ __ ] monster
universe like dark universe could be a
store in a mall that you go to buy like
it's expensive gifts but for Goths like
that we should open that [ __ ] door
man we got on the phone hello doc you
too baby jeez that could totally work
like what is the story when you go into
the mall hot top hot job they got a
spin-off store called box lunch or hot
tunas intership the talk of universe
could totally be a spin-off store right
yeah everything is [ __ ] black and
maroon and doesn't Morrissey plays a lot
of stalls Oh candles you make some
[ __ ] money well we don't need this
show anymore we're off to sell our where
is a dark universe at your local mall
kids like what's a mall that's [ __ ]
I may be kids out here to go to the mall
but I was somewhere recently we're like
you know what do kids do they like we
hang out the mall I'm like what still
like you get a time machine and then go
back to the 80s and yeah but they do
this smalls are still driving the
proposed not sure to what you hear in
the news did you not get the Internet in
this town people like I tuned in to the
show not for the [ __ ] mall fat man on
walls man get to the news I all the all
the scripts the pretty dark universe is
coming from Universal and you can't stop
it's coming like Frankenstein lumber a
notch in [ __ ] so so Tom Cruise is
kicking off in the mummy and he's not
the mummy he's a guy who's like holy
[ __ ] it's the mommy like the fortune up
there guy Nick Morton I think his name
is yeah which are gonna possibly carry
him over from movie to movie I think so
and I think Russell Crowe's dr. Jekyll
is sort of the glue that is he heads up
some weird-ass [ __ ] company called
the per diem organization that's charged
with tracking the world's monsters
because he's a monster - yes be a
monster fight monsters or gather them
together and then one day they'll put
them all together to fight a common
enemy use monsters to fight a common
enemy as a theme and taken directly they
didn't take it from but yeah what was my
my my friends Brian and Walter
did a comic book called worthy undead
was that it were the end up which I used
that same very elect Dean
let's bring the monsters and make them
fight on behalf of the thick they did
that DC Comics - didn't they like
Frankenstein and Wilbur Angelo yeah yeah
we're recruited to fight against you
know the dance why wouldn't you there
was also once upon a time there's a
comic book that I think he got optioned
for a movie that never got made it was
like Dracula versus a young dead that it
was that Dracula was fighting on the
side of mankind against zombies because
vampires
needless to say prey on humans and they
need to protect their food source oh so
that's how weird super we need them oh
my god that's [ __ ] dope because
they're human being you're like death by
drowning or death by shore right like
they will keep us alive and let us
breathe because they need more of us but
they will also take care of the gigantic
still threat that we can't deal with
does the enemy my enemy my friend indeed
I would watch the [ __ ] that movie was
a good idea let's hang it nobody's
making a [ __ ] we claim the idea of
different empires we're coming in 2018
so yeah they announced the cast of their
their monster verse okay you get Tom
Cruise is Nick morning fortune hunter
one of those famous monsters in
universal history yeah Tom name is Nick
because dick would be weird for the hero
of a movie especially dick Martin oh um
Johnny Depp it's signed on to play The
Invisible Man
I what must be like to work with Johnny
Depp tell us mmm insert Tuscan yogas
clip here ooh blue what would it be like
to work successfully blue blank screen I
I mean I worked successfully and he's
wonderful actor unfortunately those
movies didn't really connect with the
world but this will who's he playing I
mean this will be playing The Invisible
Man so he will be the Invisible Man yeah
which also seems a bit like what we do
here in fat man Batman mark says things
and I repeat it it seems like the most
Johnny Depp role ever pop though because
like he seems to be very fond of
covering himself and makeup and
subsuming his legs disappear into the
performance well now he can flat-out
disappear by performance once again
voice will be most the most
the effect of his character and his
voice choice is usually what people go
like I like that yeah so sofia boutella
is the mummy herself she's in the movie
she's in the movie and they got [ __ ]
xavier bargue in to play Frankenstein's
monster oh that's that's pretty good
[ __ ] back yeah that's good casting
why isn't that the big news like that's
that's pretty good casting I could see
that now and like that's the firt bite
of Frankenstein that is really [ __ ] No
Country for Old Men yeah it's on jerk
who Anton Chigurh
was his name in No Country for Old Men
that was his name what was his name the
Bond movie we're at half the face was
like we took out his face jaws like we
offered put it back in the house [ __ ]
up up like I've never seen that coming
[ __ ] a like saggy face oh my god is
that even possible my wife's like No
well movies come on one day we'll be
because somebody dreamed it up on it I'm
not good casting right on that is [ __ ]
he's got an awesome face worse I'm just
like Romeo they're listening well if he
ever listened to the show right why is
that awesome casting dude because my
face is why yeah you think I look like a
monster you know who didn't think I look
like a monster Penelope Cruz yes
you know who as your mama I [ __ ] all
your mothers but your mom has come to me
like that with the press conference
announcing Javier Bardem at swag it's
time we're really off the rest this is
but you heard it here first he's gonna
[ __ ] all your mothers I'm going to put
it on your [ __ ] in your house with your
mama are damn at it again thank you how
are you ready anyway come see our new
movie probably it's not only that on
product we have Bride of Frankenstein is
the first one after the money so who's
going to be the bug they haven't cast it
yet they're casting their casting now
they will announce the bride soon it's
funny cuz she's the main character by
now it's the brain comes first Bride of
Frankenstein and he's not even saying
he's a big science monster so she should
be bride of the monster mmm right a
Frankenstein monster like too many words
yeah just plugging the bride like can we
get that one thank you
I really like that movie man who played
the monster I can't oh is a clencher
band Clancy
yeah going way back I love it then
Jennifer Beals was the by staying with
dr. Funkenstein to be most emo dr.
Franklin and that man is on otehr is in
that member he was due I will kill him
say curriculum a pet perhaps dark
universe is coming it's coming
you can nobody stopping it and boy it
looks expensive they're gonna spend all
the money I mean good lord alright so
that's good thing that's good what else
we got we get out of here get off the
set dogs walking on set a [ __ ] in this
and like rural America all just walking
through this mo Alamo Drafthouse decided
that it would be an awesome idea and I
see no fault in their logic to hold
one-woman screenings fan screenings
we're doing they've absolutely been kind
of seeding the word of Wonder Woman and
events in la la in New York and Salim I
was like you know let's just have a
ladies only one woman screaming let's
what [ __ ] girl power let's just woman
only screening that is outrage is
nothing in me I mean I'm sure nobody got
mad about this because it's a good idea
and fun because it's a good idea I mean
yes it's marketing in his total
marketing and that's fine but also it's
[ __ ] Wonder Woman like what how
people I was at the screening I want to
we want to say meaning we want to see
that screening on Wednesday was like a
advance hype screaming yeah fans fan
screening as lights went down right
before the [ __ ] credits start some
girl yelled out and the back cool girl
she's a woman she's got been waiting my
whole life for this you know that's yeah
love that's awesome like so apparently
forty nine percent of the internet got
butthurt about it
I wonder which side Little Women gone
like we don't want that we don't want
anything for us this is we demand
integrated screenings how [ __ ] like
man if we had insect overlords nobody
would give a [ __ ] about this you think
they'd complain about like the ladies
only screening Wonder Woman's I can't go
to I think it's unfair what about the
men only screenings what are they going
to start those but if we had insect
overlords
nothing people there like we all got to
band together to fight the insect
overlords and [ __ ] like what about the
women only wonder women screaming snug
I'll deal with that another time we have
more pressing issues people are [ __ ]
on people [ __ ] baffle me borrow a
line from good ones
why would I don't get mad about that
because it's a thing that you don't get
to have and I want it because they have
it and just in principle it's a
principle it's a principle thing and
like listen there there's absolutely a
line that Wonderwoman belongs to
everybody she just doesn't belong to
women and yet I think and yet the fact
that this is the first female led
superhero movie there are 3,000 theaters
showing this [ __ ] movie on Friday
there's maybe one two or three let's say
[ __ ] max five that are for women only
yearning up set it up I also have just
one screening not like you every time I
know they've added it yeah the first one
was so successful at second but if
that's one [ __ ] but I've got a good
funny the theater won't ever let dudes
in its the screening just focus your
rage into something useful
like jerk off don't if next time you
think like I'm gonna this pisses me off
you mean I couldn't go to the screen
even if I wanted to even though I don't
live in this [ __ ] state and I'm
probably not going to go see Wonder
Woman well I'm gonna go [ __ ] and focus
my rage on the internet for you waste
your time just stop and go like who
would I rather masturbate even [ __ ]
hates debate would I rather succumb
wouldn't come and feel better getting
anything I'm about to do here let me see
and you'll do it you're like well I was
satisfying let me try this oh my god
everything's right
everything's around give a [ __ ] about a
wonderful this week I can't go to what
was wrong with me think yeah and I mean
and nobody complained basically Fifty
Shades of Grey were nothing but women
only screenings and that was totally
fine come on guys you know what I this
doesn't offend me at least man let me
tell you something if I got some theater
like we only do fat guy screenings on
Fridays to come the [ __ ] fat guy I'd
be like alright what a weird coincidence
okay you just gonna bring popcorn to the
seat for me what exactly makes it
guy night good night my entire week do
you bring the fat guy through to me
because they're a tube but you should
lower into my fake you can't watch the
movie at home
I'll pay theater prices then you get
into a big argument of shrinking
exhibition window and it's just
something it's a whole thing
no long story short you know I can't
even get off their dicks Alamo
Drafthouse one of the greatest
organizations on the planet you know
there are some places where it's like
I'm not an investor but if I could
invest money there places I'd invest in
[ __ ] if there was a way to invest in
Apple I would do that would you know if
there was a way to invest in what else
do I use like the [ __ ] the deck that I
record my podcasts on if there was a way
to investing weed I would do that if
only there was a market for such things
but at but if I was an investor I would
[ __ ] invest in the Alamo Drafthouse
like separately and I leave in that what
they do it's like oh my god that's so
smart you can eat chicken and watch a
movie and have a beer if you want a beer
I want to ice tea unsweetened I can have
an unsweetened iced tea and [ __ ]
chicken and fries while I edit fries
see that's how I got a ding to the meal
mark god dammit why couldn't I have just
add the chicken and the fries yeah I'm
not sure she watches me
I mean if you're not going to do this
but I got an unsweetened iced tea so it
all balanced that's alright but that's
the cannibal with cheeseburgers in a tab
that's the kind of [ __ ] you can do at
the helm I dropped I've never been to
that really rule do as they call well
I've never been to an Alamo Drafthouse
I'm a really great
I heard legends of yeah the one I was in
Austin but I went to that grand great
great granddaddy of them all well the
one that they liked like we spent a [ __ ]
ton more building it out with themed
rooms you could play karaoke and [ __ ]
like oh it's like madness but it's like
it's what every movie theater should be
it feels like it's a party every time I
know it's become the commercial for
Alamo Drafthouse but it's like it's a
[ __ ] party every time you go to the
movies I went to see what did I go see
oh we went to the Wonder Woman premier
and the I'm bitching or anything like
that everyone was wonderful but the you
know and some food about a little
something pretty effort I drove 20
minutes
I would like some snacks and you know
it's a simple kind of like here's your
corn it's I like it when they went to
here we added a little touch to a little
something special like where's my
identity you walk around Alamo
Drafthouse you get the impression it was
not made by corporation but people don't
I fell in love with the idea the draft
house again commercial for draft house
uh okay math good place they announced
they were doing these lower the ring
screenings where they were screening the
entire trilogy like fellowship all the
way Return of the King and then you
would eat they bring you food along the
way which is what the hobbits ate so
it's like you know the beginning you
like rabbit means do and then you get
like the lemmas bread which is fun a
shortbread cookies and then you get like
hey when [ __ ] the elf play so we have
an awesome L food how awesome and then
by the end it says gruel because you're
on the slopes of Mount Doom and you're
sucked in at the end is it a giant eagle
that everybody eats because it shows I
mean favor giant [ __ ] turkey legs
like hands Thank You bird but that level
of both kuelen airy engagement and pen
and curating the actual screenings yeah
like in league and his Alamo Drafthouse
we salute you ready go alright so the
woman only Wonder Woman screening coming
up with the draft house but I think
they're sold out so good country but no
that's not true
they've opened expanded it it was just
doing a one draft house screen now
they're expanding it to I think they
have a draft house in Colorado and they
have some new booklet in San Francisco
wherever the draft houses are I believe
they're having their hosting women only
Wonder Woman screen because there's a
lot of like appreciation for dance basic
for it and some people don't want to go
sit next to somebody who's just like
this bulge at Bonkerz move a marble
forever or whatever the [ __ ] or you know
they yeah you just want to see the movie
or monks a bunch of women is their
character they've loved her forever and
stuff you know who else has women only
screenings AMC they have mommy
screenings on like 10:30 11 o'clock in
the mornings on Tuesdays so you can be a
mom who never gets to go out to the
movies with like an infant or whatever
in a theater full of moms with infants
and it's just you know what everybody's
kid is going to be screaming everybody's
kid as we appear in the ass but you want
to go see a [ __ ] movie we're making a
safe space for you to do that
nobody [ __ ] about that where's all
the complaints or that yeah
like where's all the [ __ ] dads with
it like I want to go to
no there's on a dad screening every
screenings all right man moving on from
that we're done being political yes said
we're going to be a little bit sad we're
gonna be memorial is that really before
we about let's do this for if you don't
do that before that
DC Super girls is having a TV show huh
there were little shorts on the internet
and I don't know where else they ran it
but I love them I love the theme song
get your cape on and let's take fly we
can be like wow okay and what is it
something time save the wear of sand
crime get your cape and talking up with
DC super hero girls it's good they're
fun they take the entire DC Universe and
they stick him in like a [ __ ] high
school setting some school set what a
[ __ ] would you not do that it's adorable
so fun it's adorable [ __ ] show and
the line of products that they made for
it like the toys and [ __ ] look fantastic
I know burning the girl who designed a
lot of them I follow her on Instagram
and she's genius that's awesome she says
she did a picture of Giglio Gosar's
picture it still hangs on my kids wall
and she's a picture of me and Ralph once
really good Scott like this beautiful
animation stuff so she designed the look
of those characters gave Batgirl the
hoodie with the gun it's great dope [ __ ]
it's like Wonder Woman Supergirl Batgirl
they're adding bumblebees Akana
and Jessica Cruz who's a Green Lantern
oh they're adding a lady Hispanic Green
Lantern and it's looking very cool like
yeah why not and everyone's around and
like you know the competing teams are
like oh it's the the female Furies like
Sheena and stuff like she had the main
girl in high school and stuff like that
Harley Quinn is the jokester she's also
there good stuff yeah so they saw her
our chicken is up who's doing it
I'm never Network one of those animation
Sam register is a kid producer and
Lauren Faust I think is heading it up
and she did my little pony but the new
one yeah and she created the brony
cruise a crazy and the pop-up the
Powerpuff Girls reboot yeah yeah which I
haven't watched oh is it I have a lucky
day I love them against a girl I [ __ ]
love to talk craig mccracken i was
absolute [ __ ] genius man Oh Joe Joe
Joe
I mean you know I was like I've watched
it I started watching it because I had a
little daughter who was watching it and
like then I was like this is if it's a
straight-out comedy Jackie I with the
rug Fox is trying to tear into that room
tear [ __ ] up all right we end today's
episode with on a sad note we do Sir
Roger Moore for a vast part of my life
he was my James Bond mine too I cannot
lie brad's James wasn't he does it was
my first bond the first Bond movie I
ever saw was never say never again the
oh my god really yeah you know honestly
the first Bond movie no because I saw I
saw a lot of Roger Moore's in the
theater but the first Sean Connery Bond
movie I saw was never say never again
with Kim Basinger yeah they play video
games la storia Brown dollar yes any
[ __ ] grabs this [ __ ] and throws it in
this place and it's like James Bond
you're not a good flick but Roger Moore
was the bond when we were children he
had replaced first there was Sean
Connery then George Lazenby came in for
like a red hot minute for hot beat and
then Roger Moore took it over and you
know Spy Who Loved Me Live and Let Die
Moonraker Golden Gun cycle of me which I
said I'm you to kill octopus octopus II
was the one my mom wouldn't let me watch
she's called Octopussy there's words
right in the title mark you cantí yes
that's not good for you but mom it's
only more atoms I don't care if it was a
good tattoo and that was rated ours
nobody sexy named mod like multiband ski
[Music]
there was a time when or your James Bond
would you know do something heroic and
then make a dry quip about it sounds
familiar they do it on all these
superhero movies all the time this [ __ ]
originated in James Bond movies huge
action sequence many people dead pithy
response at the end yes well you know
you electrocute odd-job you then say
shocking Arnold would later go on to
steal it to be like that's a good idea
zossimov you're frozen
you're Tommy
nada boomer I used to see you everybody
owes everything to Roger more no yeah he
was a wonderful bond at the end of his
life had gotten a little bit trouble
remember it was just like I don't think
it yourself what should be bonded
everyone was like Shh come on here look
there 88 years old hop it we can ride it
out man but other than that from all
reports and it's like a very sweet
cherub worked charitable events was a
big animal lover help the animal
community and stuff like that there was
this great story that I mean the
community helped them rise and take over
plan of the apes is all because of Roger
Moore yeah it was in a rolling stone it
was this bono thing from a few years
back where he talks about being at this
hotel in Monaco and he couldn't get into
the hotel because he's dressed as [ __ ]
Bono and this was a high-end classy
establishment and so he's standing in
the lobby and like a vest in a t-shirt
ripped jeans and his hair because he's
Bono and he wants to go in and [ __ ]
Roger Moore walks in and there's like
Bono
what's the problem like why I can't I'm
not just like that's fine Lord will deal
with it and so Roger Moore talks to the
guy says it's alright [ __ ] Bono and
BIOS idea I'm gonna go and meet jay-z do
you want to meet jay-z and Roger Moore's
like who's that jay-z that biggest
rapper in the world and bond I was like
that [ __ ] it let's go me jay-z and then
he's a little concerned because here's a
75 year old white dude is going to go
meet a 31 year old rap mogul and had no
Monte Carlo in Monte Carlo and had no
idea of jay-z knew who the hell Roger
Moore was and then he walks over and
jay-z sitting with like you know his
entire phalanx of awesome dudes like
I've been [ __ ] Kanye West might've
been there Beyonce was there and
suddenly it's [ __ ] James Bond it be
her holy in bottles like it it turns out
that everybody loves James Bond
and you know the image of James Bond the
super refined ultra cool ladies man
gadgets money luxury plays directly into
everything that rap is about mmm you
know and so in the same way that
Scarface for some reason was some huge
with Trump back in the door Trump back
in the day rug and James Bond has always
been just rolling right there that
that's an awesome charming story
somewhere there must be a
of all them together to have imaginative
but at the same time you the character
has gone through many permutations and
incarnations with different actors the
current incarnation of bond very yeah
it's very like harkening bomb serious
hearkening back to a Connery bond for
which were as light as he was like he
was a bruiser yeah he was a little bit
of a thug and that's absolutely what
they embrace now but Roger Moore was
like fun bond he was how they find fun
bond do you remember he was in the st.
use the original Simon Templar that
employs saying and I say TV you and they
looked at and they're like wow he's kind
of yeah kind of childish you know and I
think they wanted him when Connery
stepped down but he was still committed
out of the st. George they went with
George Lazenby who turns out to have
been an erroneous decision and then they
finally worked their way back around to
Roger Moore who did like seven or eight
of them Kim Daly was a bond once to be
Dalton Timmy's all can feel like when we
took the American bond what anymore
Timothy dawn do you do it once or twice
you did it twice so Lazenby or lazon B
is the only guy who ever did bond once
not counting David Niven who gentlemen
Casino Royale with Woody Allen yes
interesting that's all the bond we got
for you man that's it fairly well the
bond hotline ringing in right now hello
what was that there was another bond we
forgot there it is folks that's all the
news we got to print man for fat man I'm
Batman I'm Kevin Smith and I'm up for
now come back next episode will probably
be reviewing the Wonder Woman mmm
same bat-time same bat-channel smack
gets calm or youtube.com slash Kevin
Smith
[Music]
you
[Music]